i initially started um
selling drugs like i said thinking i'm
going to help
with just simple things i just want to
tell my mother with an apartment
i wanted some twin beds for my brother
and i simple things
microwaves things that i saw other
people have that we didn't have
and i did all those things to my mother
you know um
but in a way i destroyed
my own household in doing so
and then went to prison
i started selling drugs when i was 10.
but it wasn't really
selling drugs i was just carrying drugs
for the
landlord of the house that we were
staying in temporarily it was like a
favor
and um since i knew it was temporarily
and i knew the situation that we had
going where we were in situations we
didn't have hot water
we didn't have uh lights we didn't have
gas
i was happy that he was letting us stay
there you know and
i thought how could i make this last
longer and i thought it would be by
introducing myself to his business he
had a grocery store
on um fulton street in brooklyn and
he sold cocaine out of it and my job was
really to clean
the cans and clean the store have
everything presentable
but um i used to see that they were
sending these little tin foils
out to cashier and i decided to get
curious i
figured what it was and when they
weren't unable to do it themselves the
owner or his mother or his brother
because they were busy in the back or
upstairs they had an apartment upstairs
it was a commercial use building
i decided to sell some of them to the
people that would come in that i knew
would um come in prior and that's
initially how i started selling drugs
and i was just trying to figure a way to
make more money so we could stay in the
apartment
that basically was being lent to us
but that introduction led me into um
a whole lifestyle that i'm still paying
for today
and um you know i'm paying for it in
different ways mostly psychologically at
this point
because some things you can't get out
your head it's not always
about making money and you don't always
make money in any business
a lot of people fail to realize that but
that's what it is
so by taking those steps and selling and
pushing that aluminum foil out
to cash register it took me into
carrying drugs and then selling drugs
and then accepting that as a way of
lifestyle in order to never be as poor
as we were
the time came when he kicked us out of
there
he kicked us out of there we didn't have
money to pay him we went through a cycle
of you know
you move from this address to that
address welfare has to then re-establish
a new address
and before they start sending money for
rent it's a
sort of a bureaucracy but um when you're
in that situation as far as being
homeless or
or at the edge of it you learn different
survival skills so
we made the best out of it in doing so
though we were
we were exposed to different places at
different times and now i knew
about cocaine so um everywhere i went i
tried to see how i was going to make
money tell my mother
uh you grow fast though in that business
and so
at some point it stopped being about
certain drugs and it became you also got
to kill people
because they're trying to kill you or
they're going to take away the one thing
that you got that you're trying to save
your family with
and shooting started and murders started
happening
before you know it um daily life
consisted as a teenager
carrying at least one gun at 18
carrying a gun and a bulletproof vest
things were escalating where you have to
do more and more to try to stay alive a
bigger gun more bullets extra clips
blah blah blah so the the years that i'm
discussing with you
as far as being homeless as a child were
all of the 80s of them
some of the 70s and all up into the 80s
up until 88
which is when i established with my
business partner dietong uh
yellowtop and we started selling crack
cocaine 107th street in columbus avenue
manhattan new york city
and before you know it bodies just
dropping
and shootings are occurring and lawyers
are being introduced into our lives
but we were growing in the business so
we um pretty much were engulfed by that
and
accepted that as a way of doing business
everything that was happening was
was um justified as a way of business
how much money and you know we went from
selling just
when we started the business um 500
for crack all night we stood out there
and then we would go to school in the
morning
and then it became where every day was a
thousand valves of crack they were
selling
and fast forwarding that at our highest
peak we would sell thirty thousand
units thirty thousand cracks a day
deuces or trays two dollar bottles of
three dollar bottles
um and some of the surveillance footage
that the cops
well not really the cops because we
never had problems with blue and white
cops they never
they never was a threat to us but the
task force that or did arrest us
hiu homicide investigative unit they
compiled surveillance
footage of us and you see you know 300
people online
waiting to purchase crack cocaine you
know and
and we had guys on the corner with a
walkie-talkie or with a headset and the
guy in the middle of the block
and then the cops for years couldn't
arrest nobody not one
not one ytc member because the white the
ytc operation consisted of an abandoned
building
that is completely sealed except for a
brick and a wall it looks like one brick
but obviously there's layers of bricks
that i removed when i when i got into
that building
in order for us to have an operation
from the inside of the building so
literally
you can stick your hand up to your
forearm if you're buying crack
but you never know who you're buying it
from and that operation lasted for five
years like that
continuing to grow and grow and grow
until until our arrest when it was
alleged
that we were making five million dollars
a year and um
by then we were charged with 10
homicides
14 attempting murders paying off the
police
and a number of other crimes including
you know weapon possessions a
ton of guns grenades silencers um pipe
bombs everything that you could think
about that uh
destroy his life we had and we had a lot
of it
and that was 1994 when we went down
now going back again um
when you're a young kid and you're
making thousands of dollars a day you
know and you ten thousand dollars
becomes nothing to you you want more
than that you know a week
um you get a lot of false sense of power
and and your ego grows and and you make
a lot of bad decisions
you know you don't you don't have to be
bad to make bad there's good people make
bad decisions too but
a lot of the decisions we made if not
all were bad
i say if not all because bad people do
good things too
you know so i have saved um lives i've
kept people
from being killed but but i'm also
responsible for ordering
a lot of violence so at this point in
at this point in my life um
i'm like i walk heavy because some
things you can't wash away some things
you can't just roll off your back and
some things you can't just dismiss
you know and so i'm carrying with a lot
of regret
not only with the drug dealing because
um
you know it gets deeper than that as i
said but with the murder
you know nowhere you go no no no amount
of drinks that you drink
could get you to ever not have been a
murderer if you're already murdered you
get that
so you can't wash that away you change
somebody's life you change
um somebody's family's lives somebody's
kids lives if they have kids
and there's a time when you mature and
you grow there's nothing that you could
do
to um express remorse for that you could
say sorry and i have i've apologized to
the mother at least of one of my victims
but you cannot get it out of your head
man no matter what you do
so i feel that [ __ ] growing inside of me
sometimes
and um and weighing me down
because i want to do better i want to
look i want to be looked as
as a better person but there's always
that especially nowadays when somebody
meets you and they just google you as
they walk away and then boom
you may never see them again that may be
the person that was going to change your
life you know it could be an employee it
could be a business partner could be a
it could be a lover whatever it is but
it's a lot to carry and what do you do
when it's up to you and you're the one
that made those decisions you know
um the the people on the outside they
look at me
or people like me because there's not
many people like me around
people from that ever have died or
they're in prison or were killed or
severely strung out on drugs you know
but a lot of us are not alive no more
or here to tell the story
in general people look at me and they
just think about that ytc
but there's much more to that there's
much more
than than than just that um
sometimes when you look at people for
who they were and you don't give them
credit for who they trying to become who
they're trying to
uh um be then all they're gonna give
back is that
which you know them to be you know so
it's better always always to welcome
people
into the stages of their life that
they're trying to um
um conquer and and introduce themselves
into
i'm i don't want to be known as a drug
dealer i'm not a drug dealer
i don't want to be known as a killer but
i'm responsible for death
so what i want to be known for now is
for my writing or for my projects for my
content
and and that's what i'm looking forward
to
where i'll um finally accomplish it i
don't know but that's what i'm trying to
do and that's
that's that's what i'm going to stick to
um steadfastly you know i'm not i'm not
going to detour from that because that's
the
for the first time in my life i smile
when i think about
uh coming on the software underbelly
show
you know that excites me before it might
be
nah i'm about to go over here and make a
move now
you know in other words i don't live for
uh for friday nights no more i live for
saturday mornings you know
and it's a whole better way of thinking
and seeing i know
now irish people jewish people uh mostly
white people that i didn't know before
and in my heart when you coming up they
teach you to hate the white man it's the
white man's
fault that you hear and there and
there's plenty of history that could um
certify that as true but then every
white man that's your enemy
every white man that's a cop and every
cop being bad and every white man ain't
out to get you
simple as that and i've i've um
persevered by just continuing
and that's what everybody else could do
any situation that's been thrown at me
i've tried to um overcome it prison
multiple times people have tried to kill
me
my own poverty when i was a young child
when i when i was um
released i only had a place to live for
32 days
before the woman that i was with kicked
me out of her house
and um that's a shock for a guy on life
parole
and who who who is me because i'm not a
regular dude
and and i claim my own um or i demand my
own respect right so
for you to get kicked out of where
you're living at
on life parole it's not about getting
kicked out you're on life parole that
means you could get violated and get
sent back to state prison
depending on what move you make after
being kicked out
i violated my parole that day because i
had to
go somewhere so i headed back to my old
neighborhood and that's where i
you know that's where i got on my feet
but
for me for a guy that i was raising as
the homeless kid was in the shelter
system who like
who got onto the wrong thing so then
went to prison
huh you were born where in puerto rico i
was born in puerto rico
and um i was raised in new york city but
it was uh tumultuous because of the
homelessness and
and the lack of opportunity so
for me to be on parole
for life i thought it was i think it's a
miracle that i was released
tell you truth you know it was through
prayers that my mother had gone and she
was calling every radio
christian show i think she could think
of trying to get prayers for my parole
you know
but um when i got paroled
my my legs wobbled when i received the
letter because i did not expect it
you know and now to be out it's delicate
you know you're thinking
somebody made a [ __ ] mistake they let
me out i carry the the paper that says
i'm released with me for a year in my
wallet
in case you know you know after a while
i started to think this is pretty stupid
what i'm doing but i still held on to it
right
but i felt like yo in case they'd come
at me i could show i was released
and that's how crazy it was i went to
the train station try to get a token
and the lady laughed at me talking about
do you want a token for
i'm gonna get on the train she told me
it's metro cards
i'm like what's the metro car so you
know you go through those things when
you release your baby bro
you you're being released to a world
that's new to you and to people that are
new to you and to a lifestyle that's new
to you
you're not who you were you might think
you that person in your mind but that's
not who you are no more you're in a new
a new place and to be on parole
and to have to go to a shelter because
you got kicked out is
is um for me at least was traumatic
then i got to the door of the shelter
and they didn't want to let me in
because of my record
so i'm like now what so i violated
parole because
i said [ __ ] it i'm going back 27th
street that's what i did and i overcame
that
just like everything else but you take
your you take your um
you know you take your bruises as you go
through life and my bruises have been
more like contusions you know because
they
they are you know they're significant
man it's not easy to do a
life sentence that's what i was doing so
every day you wonder if you're ever
getting out
and it don't matter how many programs
you do and how how much you do to better
yourself
because you're doing life so there's
nothing
legally that you could do to get out of
that if they decide to keep you for that
time
but you know i still continued i did
everything i could do inside and i got
into helping other people
i started working with the blind and
that was my um
my favorite my favorite thing to do
because i knew i'm helping somebody
and i had a great guy his name was halit
he's from turkey
on a a real gangster prison
people think prisons are filled with
gangsters but they're not there's only a
few
and he's one of them but he was also a
gentleman and he taught me a lot
he was blind he was from turkey he had
the biggest
drug sale in new york city history
and um and he had the same judge i had
and the same task force that arrested
my crew arrested him his sale was for
100 kilos of heroin
he um i think at trump plaza like that
but i learned from him i've been with
the worst people you could think about
in the worst places
and i've learned from all of them from
the happy land killer
i've learned from david berkel is what
you learn from david berkel is i learned
different scriptures of the bible that
he shared with me and that's what he
shares
so that's what i got from him and i've
learned from different
people man i've been in prison with with
fbi agents
with cops with judges with different
people and there's something to learn
from all of them
and a lot of them have changed their
perspective once they see
what what they were um hurraying about
is not really
what it's all sold to be as far as
prison and rehabilitation and all that
[ __ ] because
that's a joke at least in new york state
um it is
there's no rehabilitation i said it's
just a big place for you to either
get worse or get better on your own in
order for you to get better on your own
you got to want that
and then you'll seek it out on yourself
similar to slaves in the back in the
days that wanted to learn how to read
and stole books when they're masters you
know
when you want to do something you're
going to do it and nobody's going to
stop you from doing it
and um that's been sort of my life
trying to figure out how to do things on
my own
my father never was around still ain't
around
i know him he knows me he knows my
brother obviously but he's just
decided to never do nothing for us tell
me about your family how you grew up
i grew up with my mom my brother my
sister my mom's very shy
she's you know she don't drink she don't
get high she's um
always at home uh she got lied to by the
same guy which was my father
and that's how my brother and i were
conceived but he never
has i've never had a happy i've never
had a birthday party even when i had
money
but i never had a i don't know a
birthday party as a child
or christmas and all that [ __ ] there was
none of that
i only asked for my father from my
father one thing one time i was for
boxing gloves and i'm still waiting for
them
and he's always been employed he has the
same jobs today that he's always had
and um his other kids they all
gainfully employed and have college
education
my brother and i don't my brother and i
have had to survive
however we figured it out that's it
however we figured it out that's how we
had to go about it but um
we became experts at that and he's good
and i'm good
tell me about your sister my sister
my sister was my original role model
and she told me how to count she was
pretty fly got guys whistling at her i'm
turning around sticking the middle
finger up at them that's the kind of
relationship we had
uh at one time maybe my brother jumped
up because she was scolding me or him
and we were like eight and nine years
old we just jumped on a
that's tony that's a crazy memory but i
don't have many with her
my sister because we were so um
displaced
you know she would stay with her cousin
and my brother would stay with this on
and maybe i stay over here with my
mother this week and then we switched
the whole program around
in order to like try to um lessen the
burden on the person that we're staying
with
we separated that way so that allowed my
sister at times to have more freedom
that she should have
with other cousins that were older and
she started um
getting high with what in the beginning
i don't know i'm guessing
it was cocaine but that um
that led her to eventually start smoking
crack also and it was right before i hit
the streets
but when i hit the streets she knew and
um
she she's actually i'm i'm sure she's
purchased yellow tops before
so uh my relationship with my sister
ended up deteriorating because i really
didn't know how to
how to fix that problem and i only
learned this
now at the time i didn't i didn't notice
it if i would have known this i think i
would have been a little more successful
though
and um i tried different ways to try to
get her to
um to stop getting high some ways were
beating up to scare her other ways were
intimidating
other ways were pistol whipping the guys
that i would catch with that were um
selling drugs to her or have them
pistol-whipped or shot at
uh you know i've dragged out of crack
houses
took her back to my mom's house showered
her
go downstairs to get her some food by
the time i come upstairs she's either
gone
or sleep in the bathtub because that's
the first
time maybe in in um the last week that
she got
a break away from crack those few
minutes while i left her in the shower
and boom she fall asleep right in there
and that went on it was like a cat and
mouse game you know i got a
driving around to see if i find this so
my mother could get out of her window
looking for her on the streets
or i have to be threatening people or i
have to be closing down crack dealers
that are selling to her
there came a time where she'll be
setting up crack dealers by um
asking them for a hundred bottles of
crack and when they give them to us
she'll tell her i'm gonna tell my
brother that you sold to me and now
they'll
they'll forget about the hundred bottles
and tell her just forget about it you
know she was just manipulating
what she could manipulate to get high
and she got into a few problems so
i i ended up talking to a few a few of
the grocery store owners in the
neighborhood that
were open 24 hours to give her a line of
credit this way she could eat
or she could um get whatever she needs
but the
manipulation ended up being you know
she'll go buy three cars and newports
and
six boxes of pampers everything that she
could resell for the highest
in order to get money for crack
so i switched that up then i would just
give her money knowing she's gonna smoke
it but at least she's not doing
other things that are going to lead us
to trouble that didn't work out because
now i was cash so
the consumption even grew
so you know sometimes she went through
she would she would um
she would tell my girlfriend at the time
she would give the secrets about what
other girlfriends got in the
neighborhood
20 bucks 20 bucks a girl and um
different things man one time i'm on
amsterdam avenue and
some people came and told me yo we think
that there's people selling dummies
in the yellow spot and dummies um
actually it could be soap it could be
plaster
something that looks like crack but
ain't crack but in a neighborhood where
this fast moving with crack sales by the
time you sell 50
you made some money and the people
either not coming back or too far to
come back
so a lot of people do that to make money
to smoke crack and
i had to come investigate so i come
investigate i come to the building 68
west 7th street
i pull out my gun when i get to the
lobby hit the elevator
make it so that it can be used it's
stuck on the lobby and i start walking
up the steps to see
who because i couldn't believe anybody
would have the audacity to do this and
not on this block with with the with the
infamy that's associated with us
so this is gonna be a good one so i'm
going up the steps by the time i get to
the third or fourth floor
now i can start hearing movement and i'm
like damn somebody's
somebody's um definitely here you know i
gotta grip this gun a little tighter
this kept happening until i got to the
rooftop when i got to the rooftop
the way the the way the rooftop uh uh
landing is on the interior of that
building has a little
swerve so i gotta look behind there
in order to see who's there and when i
look behind it it's my sister but man
i didn't know what to do you know at
this point the
the gun is trembling in my hand and um
and she's just there with a handful of
fake yellow tops
i get out of there i sent her to puerto
rico
the next day she came back from puerto
rico the next day i saw her back on the
block
so these are things that were happening
you know those times i've pulled out of
of a car with the jersey plates and it's
and it's a john
you know trying to pay her or have had
already paid or
had already used for me it was hard
because
um you know
i didn't really know i knew how to sell
20 000 cracks a day
i could tell you how many gonna sell a
minute i could tell you um
[Music]
what recipe i'm gonna use on this block
and not on that block
but i could never figure out how to keep
one crack out of my sister's hands
so how successful could you be and what
are you really successful in
you know it's the only successful thing
you're doing
is destroying a whole hood because
you know you're worried about your
sister but there are hundreds of other
women on
line to buy your cracks and they're from
the douglas projects
are they from harlem or they from uptown
and some of them are from jersey
virginia
but they're coming there to buy your
[ __ ] and it was always like two monsters
inside of me trying to figure out you
know
um
should i be with my sister i'm gonna be
django or i'm gonna be
martin
i got stuck between the two for a long
time
and by the time i figured out
to be martin will it was too late
because now she was dying she had aids
and in the hospital this was like a
progressive thing you know sometimes
i've come around her and um
i'll come to my mom's house and um
i'm always loud and and extra so i come
in the door hey with someone
to make a lab hug or tickle her boom let
go my mom whoever else is there i'll do
the same thing with them
but this day i came in like what's that
smell and my mother's telling me to shut
up and be quiet and she ushers me into
the room my mother never accepted money
from me
in order for me to help my mom i would
have to send her to puerto rico and when
she's dead i throw her furniture out and
get a new furniture
boom that takes care of that in order
for me to for clothes
same thing buy some clothes she never
calls me never
once to this day to ask me for money
and this day she's asking me for money
so i was like
what and it was only twenty dollars that
she was asking me for
and um
um the twenty dollars was for my sister
she didn't really know what she needed
but she needed she thought she needed
twenty dollars and it was for a vaginal
infection that my sister had and that
was the smile
that i complained about when i walked in
and that's why she told me to be quiet
so when i got out the room i went to
living my sister was um sleeping on the
sofa
she like she was at rock bottom she came
on her own
whiffer came the stench of the lifestyle
the stench that i introduced myself to
when i walked in but
it's the same stench that i'm selling
you know
so it's always like um i got to be
changing on the street because
we're dealing in murder and we um
even if we don't want to it's people
shooting us you know there's been three
attempts on my life
every time i play dead there's been one
attempt in prison
and it's always about you have to get
back up
i initially started um selling drugs
like i said thinking i'm going to help
with just simple things i just want to
tell my mother with an apartment
i wanted some twin beds for my brother
and i simple things
microwaves things that i saw other
people have that we didn't have
and i did all those things for my mother
you know um
but in a way i destroyed
my own household in doing so
and then went to prison and destroyed
myself halfway through that
by trying to um survive in there now
this is the first time i'm out here
trying to live bro
and trying to do things sometimes with
no support but
i'm still going when i die it'll be
i'm gonna die trying it ain't gonna be
i'm i'm gonna die doing the wrong thing
you lost your sister how old was she 23.
right after she died her daughter died
daughter was born hiv infected
she was three years old my sister was 24
my
my niece was three years old when she
died
you know all these things um everybody
taps me on the back and tells me to get
over it
i'm already at the point i'm i'm at the
point in the age where people tell me
i'm about to
curse them out you know because that's
the best you could offer
get over it man i'm walking around with
a cemetery in my mind how you get over
that
you know i wish i didn't send those
orders out to get
to have enemies killed but
i can't how would i feel any better dead
i wouldn't be feeling and it was had to
be
it was there was a war in new york city
a crack wall
some of us had to die and some of us had
to live i was fortunate to live
but depending on the day of the week
maybe i'm not living too much i'm just
existing
and at what point do i at what point we
even i keep
asking i asked the universe at what
point we even
i've done different things i've helped
to exonerate people i was serving
life sentences i've helped to exonerate
people who were wrongfully convicted
for rapes and other crimes i've helped
people
with many different legal things and
other exonerations
you know but um i do those things to try
to even out
with all the [ __ ] i know i've done and
there's always the question of money i
never received one
penny from anybody from helping people
and i've helped people who have received
8 million and 10 million and 41 million
they really ain't i'm not i'm not
destroyed by nobody
really um paying me because i didn't
make a deal with nobody
to pay me i feel good helping people in
that way because initially when i was a
kid i wanted to be a lawyer
and that's how i got along so well with
lynn stewart
um i used to go sit with her and do
tutorials and she would teach me about
law i would go with her
to her criminal cases and arraignments
to learn
how she does things in the courtroom
this is a
known fact on the street and in the
courts
so this is the closest i've ever been to
being a lawyer by helping guys out
all of which have never knew i never
made a deal nobody i never told where i
was in the hotel mine i found out about
things and knew how to do it and i did
it and helped people
so when people always ask yo but
nobody's paying for that you shouldn't
even be doing that
i've never done it for money i'm doing
it to even myself out
with my own things you know sure i need
money sure
i'd rather buy lunch without asking how
much is that before i
get it you know but it has never been
about that
and there's evidence in my life that um
the higher power is helping me
so i'm getting something out of it i'm
meeting different people
are you religious i um
i wouldn't i i don't i don't know if you
could call me religious man i just have
now come to a point or maybe a few years
ago where
i acknowledge that it's not us that's
you know i'm not
i'm not um doing things because um i'm
so smart you know there's more to it
than that
you know and i'm not still here because
of my uh
extreme paranoia only you know i'm here
because
i'm being allowed to be out here some
something better than me and higher than
me
and cleaner than me is helping me get to
where i got to go all of us you know
we can't just want to pray with me in
the hospital or when we bleed into death
asking for mercy we have to figure out
what we believe in and respect that
there's higher powers
that definitely guide us just like this
um
very negative devilish powers too
we got you to turn your change your
thinking
my sister my sister i stopped i stopped
selling drugs right before i got
arrested
i um sold some blocks on amsterdam to
somebody
and i sold my half of the yellow top
business to tito
free tito tito's in state prison again
and um it was my sister because i would
visit her in the hospital
i'm wiping blood off of her and i'm
cleaning
her up and i'm seeing her disappear you
know deteriorate
and sometimes she's in a coma and
sometimes she's not
sometimes she recognizes us sometimes
she doesn't
but i know what led her there my mother
she knows his drugs but she doesn't know
is
she doesn't know the kind and she don't
know that it's this
crack thing and she doesn't know that
i'm a crack date
so by seeing her in the hospital
by walking past her one time and not
recognizing her
from one day to the other because of
overnight complications
and her being filled with liquid and now
being
extra big i didn't recognize i walked
right by her
those are the things that had me
thinking because right after i would
leave her
i'm returning back to the block and i
might be telling a guy yo where's the
lookout from the corner or or i ran into
somebody
listen this dude wants two thousand
bottles sell it to him right after the
hospital
so after a while visiting in the
hospital because she was there a while
i was like man there's a lot of
hypocrisy in this [ __ ] that i'm doing
for sure i'm
i'm crying and cursing about my sister
but as soon as i get from 114 shooting
amsterdam st luke's hospital to 107th
street
in columbus i'm back to being
trango so it was like a struggle like i
mentioned before i'm a bit all over the
place
but um it was a struggle trying to
figure out who to be
until i decided man i'm not doing this
[ __ ] tomorrow so i sold
my steaks and i moved
but it was too late i got a job columbia
university
as a doorman and while i figured out
what to do with the money i had as far
as cleaning it
opening a business you know i had a
couple cars a couple motorcycles i
didn't really need any toys
had a bunch of jewelry i had two places
where i was living
what i needed was to establish myself
legitimately
so i started a job it only lasted a
month though
and it was temporary until they figure
out if they want to keep me and the
second day that i was on rikers island
they called my girl
with a with a permanent position saying
that the tenants liked me and they
wanted me to be in the building
but it was too late we already had a 95
count indictment against us
and um little did i know that on that
day i was going to be kidnapped by the
nypd
and that's how that went we had sealed
secret indictments
and i was one of the first that they
picked up
prior to that there were multiple
shootings in retaliation for the
attempted murder of myself and tito
in which a cop was also shot so
things were heating up that summer some
of 94 i really didn't expect to make it
but i
my mentality at the time was i'm gonna
give it as hard as i could give it
because i know
chances are ain't gonna make it past
this year and there was a lot of
gunsmoke on columbus avenue
and amsterdam avenue and
some of it was on us and somebody was on
others i don't have any bullet holes in
me thank
god you know because um i've always seen
it coming
all three times one time a dude tried to
roll up on me with a dress
and a wig and what gave him away is his
sneakers and his ugly ass
ankles so i had to up on him another
time
three kids followed me up 107th street i
picked up on them
left them on the corner darted across
the street onto traffic
they got stuck there but i took my eyes
off of them for one minute while i
explained to some of my employees what's
going on
and they crossed the street and started
shooting i played that
um it's been a few times that people
have tried thankfully
uh no ytc member was ever killed as
tito likes to remind everybody are you
happier at this point in your life than
you were when you were at your height
selling drugs sure sure i i've never
before been happy those
that lifestyle i did um to the best of
my capability
but it was always under uh
heavy stress you know when you're 16 17
15 18 and every day
you're walking around with a gun and you
have a even even if you have a half a
brain
you know you know there's proof in the
numbers the more you do
something the greater the chances or how
that it can either fail or succeed
either way right
so you are living and working
in a war zone right the cops know you
homicide knows you tnt knows you
the narcs know you dead and confiscated
motorcycles that you have had so you
know
every branch knows you right and if all
of them know you the fbi know you too
because your fingerprints get sent to
them
so every day you playing like
let me see um how far i can make it
literally
you got a gun on you you're known for
murder you have served time
for a machine gun you have been accused
and charged with five attempted murders
i'm talking about my criminal history
right
and every day you're still in the
neighborhood and every day you still got
a gun on you you playing
who's gonna be faster the cops
that pulled up at the light and i'm
watching to see if
they hit neutral before i take off or it
could be the cops that you see in your
rear view mirror but it's going to
happen
for sure um crime don't really pay bro
um i i swore differently for a lot of
long long time but crime don't pay man
so
you under stress every day right what
what are the things that i enjoyed i'm i
have a um an addictive personality right
so i was i was am or maybe i'm taking a
break right now addicted to sex
addicted to drinking when i was released
i have an addictive personality right
did you ever do crack
no i've never done no hard drug so i've
never
tasted any not even once so you have an
addictive personality what happens
you got to be careful i learned that now
but back then
basically and when you strip everything
away
what most drug dealers are living for is
to feed their
own um insatiable desires
i don't care if it's you got you got to
have five cars and all of them have to
have the best rims
but you have to have every rolex you
have to have whatever it is
me i'm after women words right i don't
know who's listening at this point
so uh that was my trouble always
women women women women right but i
didn't look at it like what it is
addictive personality
so you you basically get living to feed
your dick sometimes you know that
and and or your ego or your
um or your rep you don't need to
you know who needs to who needs four
bmws
i i never used my cars to go anyplace
further than new york city
i lived up to block or in yonkers when i
got a condo in yonkers
i didn't know that it's about me me me
one one one it becomes a thing where you
just as sick as the as the drug addict
you're just seeking a different thing
you know and
and for any drug dealers like that you
tell the drug dealer that needs a re-up
that you don't have the kilogram that he
needs to put in his spot he's gonna be
sick he's gonna go through it he's gonna
have
emotions all kind of problems it's an
addictive lifestyle
so i never was happy then it just looked
that way it looked that way to the
people that thought that motorcycles
cars women
jewelry and money define happiness yes
i'm happier now
um sometimes i'm just
another dude that's asking how much is
that hero
first you usually see the construct i
used to see the construction workers
where i was working at
you know they got to price everything
because it's expensive or whatever
whatever they're making is not enough so
and that's just to stay in my head like
wow you gotta
you know it's bread and turkey lettuce
and tomato
but now a lot of times i've had to do
that in my life you know
man in prison there were times where i
didn't have enough money for a chunky
monkey
and that goes back to um the times
obviously i'm in prison but it goes back
to the question of
you know who are you you did all this
[ __ ] it's commissary today you don't
have two dollars and 34 cents to get a
chunky monkey from clean correctional
facilities
commissary you got to think like what
the
[ __ ] did i do there's people that are
dead there's people
that are hurt the whole community was
destroyed for years
you got kids that were born from that
time that other people consider crack
babies because they were raised without
a mother and a father and with a cell
phone
and i don't have enough to buy a chunky
monkey
that's a lesson for me in prison bro in
a maximum security prison
now of course that didn't happen often
but it has happened a few times
i just didn't have it you know so um
nothing that i did i came to the
conclusion that nothing that i did was
worth doing
because i never moved to a mansion my
mother never wanted any of that
she still don't my um my brother has
done fine all on his own to become his
own man in his own way
with his own things
so what what you know i think i um i
overdid
taking a role that was unnecessary for
me i had good intentions
but i got lost within that once i got
bit by the um
by all the things that that lifestyle
brings i never forgot my family
i'm still with them i still helped them
um
but i hurt them more than i helped them
because
i put myself in a position that i'm
still trying to get back from
and um i got to be the one that's
responsible for bringing my mother to a
prison she's never
had a summons you know and now she's
being searched
to come see her son after riding a bus
for eight hours
to sit on a visiting floor for eight
hours to then get back on the same bus
for eight hours
it's not worth it every time i go on a
visit i'm
you gotta i've gotta be butt ass naked
turn over an intro
i don't even know what my [ __ ] looks
like but half of the department of
corrections know what it looks like
it's crazy so um
the lifestyle ain't worth it and that's
what i try to tell people or preach to
people
or be people over the head with and
sometimes it's weird because
um and you know in new york city
recently there was a kid murdered by a
gang of other kids
he stabbed to death machete to death in
the bronx rest in peace to junior
and i found myself you know following
the story and
commenting about it and and blogging
about it
and somebody told me yo but that's how
you guys were
and i couldn't believe the person said
that to me while i'm trying to
advocate for better and be positive
but he was right we didn't use knives
and machetes and we didn't chase down no
kid over
whatever he's assumed to have done or
been
but murders murder and
you know you could shoot somebody or
kill somebody and
possibly forget about it i haven't but
you could walk away from it and get away
but the day you walk away from it you
leave countless people with a
literal mess to deal with with their
loved one on
on on the pavement or maybe his brains
is all over the place
and you walk away but that family has to
deal with that forever bro you don't
you know that that hole you put in
somebody they don't never get
to feel it ever man and you get a whole
tool because
if you are mature then you know what
that's worth
if you got a son you know that you would
kill for him
you know you would give your freedom for
him so you should know that the person
whom you killed had a father and a
mother that
didn't feel the same way about them and
if you know that
and you know that what you did was
[ __ ] i know what we did i know what
we did i know we did it wrong for what
we did
but i've always said and i'm not trying
to be funny by saying this i'd rather be
dead wrong than just dead
and that's the life at the time back
then that we were exposed to
um you know i didn't i certainly never
woke up and
i never been a bully but i never woke up
and bullied anybody into anything
a lot of a lot of the money i made i've
given away or i've helped other people
with it it's like a
blessing and a curse you know i've
always felt like i have to
help other people since i was a child
and still to this day today i embrace it
more
back then it was just out of a sense of
responsibility i felt i had to keep
um and that consisted of paying for
bails and paying for people's
trials that had nothing to do with me it
was just a guy i know he reached out
paying for private investigators paying
for guys girlfriends to get their hair
done and their rent and their
and their and their everything else
while they're in prison that were
working for us they made their own money
they couldn't do that for themselves but
we had uh we had a crew that we felt
like we got to take care of
so we've done good and we've done bad
but we did a lot of bad that's um
that you can't sanitize
unfortunately do you think your time in
prison might have saved your life
oh what do you mean do you mean like if
i was if i would have never got arrested
would i've been dead
yeah for sure for sure i've had a
conversation with my brother
shout out to him and um it was about
what i want him to make sure i'm wearing
at the funeral and this was 1992
we got arrested in 1994.
so in 92 i was getting ready for a
funeral but that's because i
by then i had already been by by 94 i
had been to 17 funerals
so nobody was older than 24
and there was only one guy that was 24
rest in peace to him
but the refs were 17 18 16 19.
so it was like this is the normal [ __ ]
that's going on
and i felt old i was 19 going on 20
thinking man i'm a i'm an old guy
i'm running around here because
everybody else is getting smoked
so i would have definitely been dead
they already have been three attempts
sooner or later somebody's gonna
decide no we gotta make sure chango
ain't playing that
after you shoot at them because i
already did it three times you know so i
knew that
what saves me is not going to keep
saving me because somebody's going to
make sure
so things were escalating you know like
i said that we were under surveillance
so
on 106th street in columbus avenue there
was a an undercover car
parked filming the yellow top spot in
action
told you 300 people online this is a
daily thing
300 people get dismissed in 15 minutes
and then they start piling up again
right so they're capturing all this on
film when the hit team came
the same hit team that tried to kill me
two days prior
on this day came to try to kill tito
and little do they know where they're at
they're on a hot block so it
while they're filming the yellow top
spot these three guys come
and they're pretending like they're
looking for weed and they ask
for uh one of my employees for some for
lo you know do you got any weed for sale
and tito was there so tito tells them yo
take your hoods off what you
you doing over here with hoodies on so
they take their hoodies on off
but now he kind of like pressed him so
one of them
reached and when tito sees him pulling
out his gun
one of the employees that's in the spot
tito's like yo pass the gun
it was too late for that instead that
guy pulled tear into the building
long story short they were shooting in
through the door
and tito got hit right here and in the
arm
but what happened more than that is that
the it's on
video and now these this undercover car
speeds into the spot
sound effects and they turn around
thinking those are yellow top members
and start shooting at them
they're black and spanish because they
got to fit into the neighborhood
and they're in an undercover car so a
sergeant in the backseat got hit up
he was he was um supervising the
surveillance
he's in the back seat all hell broke
loose because when
this is occurring you have multiple cars
in the neighborhood
stationed in case anything happens so
once that came over the radio
all of them convened on 107th street and
one of the shooter
of the cop got arrested he got caught
right there they beat
they beat him to elephant man status
right there you shoot a cop in new york
city
you know you you in for a long ride
so he got arrested the other guys got
away
i went to court to figure out who the
[ __ ] is this dude where he comes from
where he live at
i went to his arraignment learned he's
from brooklyn and then i pieced together
where it could be coming from and um
three days later tito was released from
the hospital and he had a few pieces to
the puzzle
and we figured out it was a
fellow from 109th street he put out
twenty thousand dollar hits hard on us
because i wouldn't let him sell drugs on
columbus avenue
and two days after that i and some
friends went over there and
saw him on 109th street and he didn't
know that we knew
so he was trying to offer me guns in
case we need you know that's a common
thing
some of us at the time in new york city
you could get a murder as
murder committed as a favor no i'm gonna
i'm gonna do this favor and kill this
guy and when i have somebody that i need
kill that i can't get it
close to you're gonna do it people would
come into those kind of uh
verbal agreements so it was nothing for
him to be telling me yo you need guns i
could give you five guns
but i know he's trying to sleep me
because i know
that the guys that just tried to kill us
came from him
so he's offering me these guns i'm just
listening to him but i'm buying
time at some point i tell him
see you later with not even with
conversation
i did like this and i'm walking away and
he got tapped on the shoulder he was
shot nine times
he lives i'm glad he's alive by the way
and you know he was shot in the neck and
his chest
and the nuts
he was severely wounded a week we
by the time we got to the corner maybe
six seven steps a cop came around the
corner
and he was scared to [ __ ] death after
hearing all those shots coming around
the corner and now he sees
a gentleman that was with me with right
by the body that's laying on the street
on the pavement so listen his hat is
here his shirt is
out his gun is out he's trying to radio
everything that he sees going on
and you hear more sirens coming and
i'm telling my god to get up because now
he's on the floor
he gets up but he leaves the gun there
and then he takes three steps and he
goes back to the gun and he picks it up
and the cop is hiding here in the car
and then more sirens are coming
everybody's disappearing hiding behind
cars this is turning into a movie
and now we're getting to the corner
some guy that's with me he's not from
new york he's only been in new york for
one day
right so he don't really know where he's
going and i'm trying to get away from
him now
so we we turn 109th street in amsterdam
avenue
and the guy takes off running towards
columbus avenue
where he was apprehended i got away with
another guy and that was that
raymond went to the hospital that's the
guy's name from 109th street
and um he lived
he was shot nine times and he lived
that's the kind of thing that was going
on on a daily basis you know
that was 12 o'clock in afternoon on a
school day and there's a school on the
block
none of this any one of us considered
because
it was a thing where we got to get him
now he just tried to get us we've been
here minding our business i tell this
guy he can't sell drugs over here and he
takes
puts his heart on us what do you do like
go work it out with him that don't exist
you know so you gotta just give him what
he tried to give you
so that's what i did um
like i said he lived he's uh
he's a colorful character i got
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned
in your life there's so many things man
i it would be i i i'd rather share a few
than just one because
give me a few it's a good answer i've
learned
not to judge i've learned that
not every time you have something to say
you should say it
i've learned um to be patient i never
was patient in my life
i wanted everything now i didn't think i
had enough time
you know how long can i live i got
between 15
to 21. i figured i got three or four
years i don't have time to do
things the way other people do then when
i was 20 i'm like i'm too old
i'm not gonna make it much longer i
can't slow down for nobody
so patience i've also learned man to
think things through
and sometimes even when your ego struck
you don't have to react a lot of times
violence comes from from
from sometimes from a verbal injury
things escalate you know
so i've learned you know you got to just
be able to be compassionate
deal with compassion instead of with
anger
and responsibility most of all man you
have to think with about the things that
you're going to do
before you do them and yeah i mean i
also mean
don't don't drink and drive but i'm
talking about a lot
more serious things that
you know may may seem
like the right thing to do but y'all
always knows when when you're up to the
wrong thing you know your stomach will
tell you or your heart will tell you
now you could ignore both of them but
your heart and your stomach will tell
you when you do
when you're up to no good and when
you're about to do something that's no
good so i learned to listen to my
stomach and my heart
now those those antidotes probably sound
a bit um
a bit hillbilly probably you know like
they come from the hill but
as simple as they are those things had i
exercised them in my
life before would have helped me a lot
more now
one of the biggest things i've learned
is to accept other people
you know a different people that i've
met have helped me and
in my prior life i wouldn't have
listened to anything they say because
they have nothing to do with the way i
have
um been brought up but allowing other
voices to come into your head
different ways different cultures
different people different languages
helps you in a way to grow into better
ways and better things better people
better circles better networking you
know
and and that's what has helped me um
it don't matter how big the guy is no
matter if this guy's pink if this guy's
homeless if she's a prostitute everybody
has something to offer
we are here doing something if i look at
a prostitute like she's dirty
there's somebody maybe partying park
avenue looking at me
on my clean day considering me dirty
there's always somebody to judge
somebody
in prison the murderers judge the rapist
and then the rapists judge the
pedophiles
and it's all downhill right but
one time i was trying to get a transfer
to clean correctional facility right
probably 1999
and my counselor was uh sharon benson
perry
and you know i have a lot of enemies
everything that's from the street is
documented it goes with you to prison
so you know you wherever you have
documented enemies
you're not going to that prison
sometimes it happens to happen with me
three times but for the most part you
won't go because you have what's called
um separations on his file it's noted to
be
he has to be kept away from you and the
same thing on your file so when they put
you in for a transfer they won't send
you nowhere where that person is at
so long story short i have a i had a lot
of enemies
and so but i wanted to transfer because
i wanted to get to sing sing
correctional facility
right and i kept bugging the counselor
and she told me one day
yo i would rather you stay here you work
for me as an hiv peer educator
um you have a leadership role and
you're bilingual i want you you know
you're doing good here you got showers
every day
um you know you don't you get two
showers in prison but she's telling me
all the good things right
she's saying you know we all know you
cooking yourself
all this and you man i have those things
somewhere else but i'm like no i want to
go
so i tell her um listen i'm not a rapist
so
whatever problems i got i'm gonna deal
with them wherever i go i'm not the only
one with those kind of problems
or or with enemies she said this to me
i would rather be raped and killed and
she just looked at me
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is she
talking about
so i'm like i don't really understand
what you're trying to tell me and she
said yeah you're not a rapist
so you're not gonna have everybody
trying to kill you but
you've done worse than rape you know
acknowledge that and and i walked away
learning
that day that you could get up from a
rape you can't get up from a bullet in
the head
so why should a murderer be any better
than a rapist
why do people welcome home
me with three murderers on my jacket but
the rapist everybody wants to talk about
and judge
it's always that somebody judging
somebody else
always the the the the downscale
as far as human beings you know the girl
with the long hair talks about the girl
with the weave
the girl with the weave talks about the
girl with no hair get it i don't
understand that we all
human and none of us is perfect and
everybody got [ __ ] and everybody got
an ugly side and and and everybody got
that nasty taste in their mouth when
they wake up
and everybody got that first dump they
got to take when they wake up
and everybody get put in the ground when
they die no matter who you are on the
same
usually size a hole and
we all the same bro the difference is
some of us are a little more polished
than others but that
you know that ain't really [ __ ] bro
i know i know millionaires that are
miserable
right here in new york right here i'm in
california tomorrow right
in new york city i know millionaires
that are miserable in prison i know
millionaires that
can't go home and will give all their
money to get a week
of freedom so i've been to all these
different places
different prisons all maximum security
prisons never a medium
and all i've been doing is absorbing and
learning you know
shout out to guillermo santo domingo and
habibi i got friends all over the place
in turkey and london
and and colombia brazil mexico have been
deported that i've all met in prison
and um i've learned from all of them
some of them i visit and i stay with
them
a week or two weeks and then i come back
home and those are friendships that i
um developed in prison and were that
were cultivated in a positive way
in a negative place you know so
um at the end of the day i got a lot out
of being in prison
i didn't want to be there and it almost
killed me i was sued
i've been i've been suicidal and
homicidal but
look i'm here i made it
all right chango thank you so much for
sharing your fascinating story
all right brother thank you this is
pretty much for me i told you
yeah i think i think we'll do another
one of these one day we got we're doing
new york
that's right next time all right thank
you
you